here's something um
pretty interesting the u.s embassy in
jamaica is
among the many embassies across the
world right now that's flying a pride
flag
we know even the embassy in kabul was uh
flying a pride flag which we could
assume at this point has been taken down
well they put one up in jamaica and some
jamaicans are not
happy about that uh they they say that
they don't want the pride flag flying in
fact they say that it's cultural
imperialism and i think they kind of
make a good point let's listen to them
and as you might be able to see in the
background the u.s embassy continues to
fly the lgbt flag lesbian gay bisexual
transgender flag
in breach of the vienna convention
articles 31e article 20 and article 41
right they are being hostile towards our
laws our culture and our own democratic
system instead of flying the jamaican
flag for emancipation they have decided
to fly that flag and that is an insult
to our country philippa davies advocacy
officer for the jamaica coalition for a
healthy society says the flag represents
life practices that threatens the
jamaican culture and the teachings of
the bible she says it also affects the
health of the society you have to
understand what that multicolored flag
represents it represents normalizing
perverse sexual behaviors and lifestyle
choices behaviors and lifestyles that
lead to disease and death our christian
duty is to speak the truth in love
protesters say they have been peacefully
protesting that the flag be taken down
since the day it was raised but are
shocked it remains on the flagpole up to
man's dependence week efforts to contact
the us consulate and a member of the
lgbtq group on friday proved futile
however the protesters say they will
continue to stand against the flying of
the rainbow colored flag describing it
as a symbol of disrespect on jamaican
soil article 20 specifically says the
only flag that should fly is their
national flag
the lgbt flag is not their national flag
their own people have not agreed to that
at all okay
well
they raised some good points i would say
and there's no response to that from the
left has no response all they could do
is ignore this kind of thing
um because if they were to
meet that head-on and offer a response
the response would be something like
well
this is not your value system but it
should be
this should be your value system
because of course i mean
we're so used to it by now
uh that that maybe we don't stop and
reflect on just how crazy this actually
is that u.s embassies are flying any
flag other than the american flag
i don't even care what flag it is
why are you flying why is the american
government flying any flag
anywhere
other than the american flag
the federal government should be flying
no flag except the american flag
should be showing no loyalty to anything
but
its own country
and then to consider what that flag is
flag showing pride in certain sexual
orientations
this is what our embassies are doing
a flag to show pride in
homosexuality or transgenderism
no matter
no matter how you even feel about that
why why is the ameri why is a federal
government
why does the federal government have
anything to say about that
at home or especially abroad
it's insane
and then meanwhile we're flying this
flag
um
to promote a value system
that many americans don't share to begin
with
but promoting it in countries
uh that certainly don't share it and if
if they're flying the american flag
anywhere that is not a western country i
mean anywhere
then they are promoting this value
system they're imposing this value
system on people who do not share it and
don't want it
so what are you gonna do
are you gonna i mean
someone should go down there
and explain to these people no you don't
yeah you you don't believe in this this
is not your value system but it should
be we will tell you what your value
system should be
no on the left when they worry about
cultural appropriation
or
cultural imperialism you hear these
kinds of phrases from them
but they're worried about i mean there
was there was some uh
ridiculous woman i think some journalist
this past week
who was upset on twitter because a white
woman had had made a cookbook
on on how to make dumplings she had made
a dumpling cookbook
and there was some leftist who was upset
about this
he said what is this white woman
making a cookbook about dumplings for
well probably she made the couple the
dumpling cookbook because she's good at
making dumplings and shows she had some
advice on how to do
that but that is cultural imperialism
according to the left
to make a food item
that
arguably originates somewhere aside from
the continental united states
that's the kind of appropriation and
cultural
imperialism they're worried about
meanwhile we're overseas flying pride
flags
trying to impose this value system
on people who do not want it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content